- [Narrator] Racism and xenophobia are,
unfortunately, everywhere.
However, one woman is
turning this into this.
Meet Germany's hate destroyer.
(light music)
In Germany, former teacher
Irmela Mensah-Schramm
has made it her life mission
to remove any neo-Nazi stickers
and graffiti around her country.
It's no each feat though.
- Nein.
- [Narrator] And how does one arm oneself
for a war against street hate?
- [Narrator] Irmela's
been covering, removing
and obscuring these
messages since the eighties.
She keeps a record of
everything she's wiped out,
all over her country.
- [Narrator] Everyday,
except for Sundays,
Irmela packs her bags and
heads off to the streets.
Sometimes she nails a
big one, like this heart.
It used to be a swastika.
Other times, it's small,
but even the crudest message
doesn't slip by.
- [Narrator] And as long as
there's hate in this world,
Irmela will be there, can in hand.